As promised, the Terminator franchise came
back... but it didn't arrive to the kind of
financial success that studio Paramount Pictures
was hoping for.
Terminator: Dark Fate, the sixth entry into
the Terminator film series that acts as a
direct sequel to 1984's Terminator and 1991's
Terminator: Judgment Day, opened in theaters
on Friday, November 1 to dismal box office
returns.
Despite having James Cameron back on board
as a producer, Deadpool director Tim Miller
behind the helm, Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Linda Hamilton in their respective roles as
the T-800 Terminator and the gun-toting badass
Sarah Connor, and a host of intriguing new
characters in the mix, Dark Fate sadly lived
up to its name facing a dark fate by earning
just $29 million domestically and $94.6 million
internationally over its opening weekend.
That's not good for a franchise trying so
desperately to redeem itself.
"If something goes wrong, this could be our
last chance — so MOVE!"
With a total debut pull of $123.6 million,
Terminator: Dark Fate hasn't come close to
recouping its reported production budget of
$185 million, which doesn't include the cost
of marketing and distribution.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, this
means that Dark Fate could end up costing
Paramount Pictures, Skydance Media, and the
now-shuttered 20th Century Fox more than $120
million.
Each company is said to have financed 30 percent
of the film's budget, which works out to about
$55.5 million a pop.
The remaining 10 percent of Dark Fate's production
budget is on the line at the Chinese conglomerate
Tencent Holdings.
THR details the worst-case scenario for Terminator:
Dark Fate as costing its financiers $130 million
in the event that the film loses its overseas
traction and winds up flopping.
A source close to the outlet has indicated
that the better-case scenario is that Paramount,
Skydance, Fox owner Disney, and Tencent may
end up eating only $110 million if Dark Fate,
quote, "does have strong legs offshore."
Still, Variety reports that Terminator: Dark
Fate is looking at a worldwide take-home of
only $180 million to $200 million dollars,
and that the film would need to earn around
$450 million total just to break even.
It would be simple to say that Dark Fate tanked
at the box office because critics and fans
absolutely hated it and think it's a massive
piece of garbage, but that would be a lie.
It seems a big reason why Terminator: Dark
Fate tanked financially isn't because everyone
thinks the film is horrible.
Rather, it appears that the films that preceded
Dark Fate the much-derided Terminator 3: Rise
of the Machines, Terminator Salvation, and
Terminator Genisys, all of which Dark Fate
actually ignores were so bad that people aren't
giving the new movie a chance.
Fewer people heading out to theaters naturally
means less revenue, and it looks as though
this is the situation in which Dark Fate is
currently stuck.
For some fans, the fact that Terminator: Dark
Fate is being touted as a franchise-reviver
might instill in them a terrible sense of
déjà vu.
After all, 2015's Terminator Genisys was also
marketed as a something of a breath of fresh
air to the struggling franchise, with Game
of Thrones' Emilia Clarke stepping into the
role of Sarah Connor, and wound up getting
ripped to shreds by everyone who saw it.
There's a strong chance people are afraid
Dark Fate is just Genisys with different packaging
which really isn't accurate.
"Never seen one like you before.
Almost human."
"I am human.
Just enhanced."
"Which means I can rip your throat out if
you piss me off."
Rotten Tomatoes reviews for Terminator: Dark
Fate are fairly solid.
The film sits at a respectable 70 percent
critical rating.
It's consensus?
"Terminator: Dark Fate represents a significant
upgrade over its immediate predecessors, even
if it lacks the thrilling firepower of the
franchise's best installments."
Sure, some critics weren't super fond of the
flick, but others found it truly enjoyable
like TheWrap's William Bibbiani, who said
of Dark Fate, quote, "This story actually
demands to be told, and it gets told with
precision and skill."
For their part, fans liked Dark Fate better
than critics did.
The film's audience rating on Rotten Tomatoes
is clocking in at 84 percent as of the making
of this video.
Overall, Terminator: Dark Fate may not be
a mind-blowing piece of cinema or a universal
crowd-pleaser, but it isn't avoid-at-all-costs
awful.
It's a pretty good film with pretty good ratings.
But regardless of what Dark Fate has going
for it Cameron returning as producer, Schwarzenegger
and Hamilton back in action, a new story to
tell, passable reviews it still floundered
at the box office.
Unless Terminator: Dark Fate somehow does
the impossible and earns an unthinkable amount
of money in the very near future, things aren't
looking good for the franchise.
What was intended to be a balm to help heal
the film series may have just made it even
sicker and possibly even pushed it to its
doom.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.